الادارات والامريكيه لطالما نجحت في رفع
سقف الدين بالرغم من الجدل السياسي
المرافق لكن لنفرض ان هذا لن يحدث او على
الاقل سيتاخر هل يمتلك الرئيس بايدن
صلاحيات تنقذ الموقف رفع سقف الفائده كان
ليكون مجرد اجراء بسيط لولا نتائج
انتخابات التجديد النصفيه التي جاءت
بالجمهوريين على راس مجلس النواب وفي هذه
الحاله الى قرار دون اقناعهم الجمهوريون
وضعوا شروطهم التي ستحد مما وصفوه باسراف
اداره بايدن في الانفاق وشبهوا سياسته
بالطفل الذي انفق امواله قبل الموعد وهو
الان يطلب المزيد
ادارته بايدن وصفت مطالب الجمهوريين
بتخفيض الميزانيه ب 4,500 مليار دولار
بمطلب تعجيزي يدمر العائلات الامريكيه
الجمهوريون عللوا ما يفعله كذا رئيس مجلس
النواب بان البلاد عاجزه عن دفع فوائد
القروض التي تم انفاقها فعليا والامر لا
يتعلق بطلب قروض جديده لانفاقها
صباحو واتخلف عن السداد الذي يخيم على
الاقتصاد الامريكي جعل قيمه التامين على
سندات الخزانه الامريكيه تفوق ديون دوله
مثل اليونان وخوفا من الصدمه جهزت الخزانه
الامريكيه اجراءات بديله البدايه من تعليق
قانون سقف الدين مؤقتا مما يسمح بالصرف
معاشات التقاعد والمعلمين حصل هذا سابقا
سبع مرات حل ثاني اقترحه ترامب سابقا لحل
ازمه الدين وهو طبع النقود بالتاكيد سيحل
ازمه السيوله لكنه سيرفع معدلات التضخم
التي تكافح اداره بايدن لكبحها ولكبح جماح
التضخم
ستضطر واشنطن لرفع الفائده لتبلغ معدلات
مغريه بما فيه الكفايه من اجل جذب اموال
المودعين الى البنوك وهو اجراء يسمح بكبح
الطلب على السلع لكن معدلات الفائده
المرتفعه بدورها ستقتل الاستثمارات وقطاع
العقارات وهنا ازمه اخرى دائره مغلقه
تجبر بايدن على استغلال صلاحياته
الدستوريه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات